in the opening scene we are introduced
to a professional diver named Jonas
Taylor and his team who are in the
middle of a rescue mission they are
trying to save the crew of a nuclear
submarine that has been destroyed Jonas
succeeds in getting some of them on
board including a doctor named Heller
but at the same time an unidentified
creature starts attacking the sub
violently with some of his crew trapped
inside the damaged submarine Jonas is
forced to make a tough decision against
Dr Heller's objections he abandons the
trapped members realizing that
attempting a rescue would lead to
certain deaths for all they narrowly
escaped just in time as the Unseen Force
obliterates the wrecked submarine the
scene then cuts to five years later
taking us to an underwater research
facility named Mana one located off the
coast of China the project is funded by
a billionaire named Jack Morris and is
spearheaded by a Chinese guy named Dr
minwei Zhang alongside his oceanographer
daughter Su Yen one day Morris arrives
at Mana one on his private helicopter
and is welcomed by Dr Zhang who then
gives him a tour of the facility he
meets several team members including the
engineer Jax the earlier Survivor Dr
Heller the remote Explorer named DJ and
the station Chief Mack their mission is
to explore the concealed potentially
deepest area of the Marianas Trench
surrounded by the hydrogen sulfide
thermocline the submersible mission is
piloted by scientists named Toshi the
wall and Jonas's ex-wife Lori initially
their exploration goes well as they
discover an abundance of previously
unknown flora and fauna beneath the
thermocline they even dispatch a
scouting Rover for further investigation
of the area however their mission takes
a perilous turn when they are
unexpectedly attacked by a massive
unidentified creature causing them to
lose communication with Mana one control
room the crew try getting power back up
and running but they are attacked again
this time Lori sustains a severe injury
from a screwdriver being stabbed into
her abdomen God damn it I knew we
shouldn't have brought screwdrivers that
man 1. the rest of the crew members hold
an urgent meeting to discuss the rescue
of the stranded crew they recognize the
need for someone capable of navigating
six miles deep into the ocean Mack can
think of no one other than Jonas for the
task So He suggests his name emphasizing
that he is the only one you can rescue
people from such a deep dangerous area
of the ocean however Dr Heller and
sooyan object to the idea fearing that
Jonas may be mentally unstable due to
his traumatic past and his claims about
unusual ocean phenomena despite their
objections Mr zhangover rules and
decides to hire Jonas for the mission
mental instability might also mean he
knows how to throw grenades off of
Cedars and in the next scene Mr
Zhang and Mack waste no time and travel
by helicopter to Thailand where Jonas
now lives a reclusive life he is now a
drunken loner who spends most of his
days in a Taiwanese bar drinking
regularly Mac and Dr Zhang meet with him
in a small apartment room at first he
tries to avoid the rescue mission
rejecting any monetary and incentives
however he changes his mind after
hearing a taped recording of Lori her
crew and the situation at Mana one
meanwhile back at Mana one sooyan takes
matters into her own hands and decides
to attempt the rescue using a mini sub
shortly after her departure Jonas
arrives at the facility and heads
directly to the rescue sub inside he
encounters suyen's daughter who
expresses her concerns about her
mother's safety Jonas assures her that
he will bring her back unharmed shortly
after the crew in the control room
performs final checks before giving
Jonas the green light he then takes a
deep breath and courageously dives into
the deep Abyss in the meantime Su Yin
manages to locate the trapped
submersible and prepares to tow it back
to the surface however at the same time
she faces an attack from a colossal
squid before the squid can Crush her
mini sub it is killed by a 75 foot long
prehistoric shark known as a Megalodon
this particular shark is the same one
Jonas encountered five years ago which
finally provides an undeniable proof of
his sanity and the existence of such
creatures it makes a noise like this
moments before the Megalodon launches an
attack on suyen Jonas lures the shark
away with some flares enabling suyin to
escape safely to the surface after this
Jonas connects his submersible to the
stranded one and successfully rescues
Lori and the wall however the Megalodon
returns for another assault so Toshi
sacrifices himself to help the others
escape stuffing a goodbye letter into
the Wall's pocket it reads I am Toshi
and I was given no character development
in this movie goodbye in the aftermath
of all of this Dr Heller offers a
sincere apology to Jonas for doubting
his earlier claims the following day the
crew discovers that the Megalodon also
known as Meg belongs to a prehistoric
shark species once considered to be
extinct as their discussion unfolds the
crew members realize that the situation
isn't over yet as the temporary breach
in the thermocline is allowed the shark
to access normal ocean waters on the
surface while deliberating on how to
tackle this new threat suyan's daughter
who is playing with an RC ball in Mana
one's underwater tunnels is frightened
by the terrifying sight of the shark it
goes like this hello it attempts to
breach the facility's hall but the
structure withstands the attack and the
shark departs after killing a small
whale it just wanted to flex a little in
order to address the problem the crew
resolves to track Meg and kill it with
poison after the Megalodon destroys
three nearby shark fin fishing ships
Jonas courageously dives into the water
to attach a tracking device to the shark
he manages to swim close enough to it
before tagging the device onto its fin
with this the rest of the crew members
start to reel him back which causes some
vibrations alerting Meg fortunately they
start the boat and manage to get Jonas
back just in the nick of time blimey
says Jonas as the next part of their
plan Su Yin descends into a shark-proof
tank in order to administer poison to
Meg while the others use Chum to lure
the shark close initially attracting
regular sharks the bait eventually
brings Meg to the scene suyian attempts
to Target its eye with the poisonous
dart but the gigantic Megalodon drags
her as well as the boat away despite
this life-threatening confrontation
suyian manages to shoot the poison dart
into Meg's mouth but unfortunately this
only agitates the large predator and it
attempts to swallow the entire cage
although the cage is unbreakable the
impact results in a cracked oxygen mask
for Su Yin putting her at risk of oxygen
depletion sensing the urgency of the
situation Jonas dives into the water to
rescue her the rest of the crew bait mag
to distract it buying Jonas some time to
free Su Yin shortly after Meg again
heads back to Jonas and suyan but before
it can harm them the effects of the
poison take hold and finally kill it
after this Jonas quickly brings suyin
back aboard and Dr Heller manages to
resuscitate her back to life the crew
then celebrates their success and the
wall takes pictures with the dead mag in
a playful prank the other crew members
May make him believe the shark is still
alive PTSD startling him for a moment
and causing him to fall into the water
amidst this celebration Jonas observes
that the shark's teeth are smaller than
the one they encountered earlier shortly
after his assumption proves to be true
as the real Meg emerges from the depths
and swallows the wall it then grabs the
younger Megalodon's corpse off the boat
causing it to capsize in the ensuing
chaos everyone is thrown into the water
and Mr Zhang is critically injured while
some of the crew members managed to
regroup on the ship Jax and Dr Heller
are still far away the Megalodon circles
back and in A Brave sacrifice Dr Heller
distracts the shark drawing its
attention away from Jax she is brutally
killed but at least she manages to save
her crew following this the surviving
crew members managed to grab the
floating motorboats and make their
escape while Morris calls for backup not
long after a helicopter arrives at the
scene and successfully drives the shark
away with a series of gunfire tragically
Mr Zhang succumbs to his injuries during
the journey back to Mana one which
leaves his daughter devastated later
that night at manawan sueyin Mourns for
her father's death while Jonas attempts
to console her the next day Morris
gathers everyone in the control room to
make an announcement he claims to have
informed the Chinese governments about
the Megalodon stating that they don't
have to risk their lives anymore
furthermore he announces that Mana one
will be shutting down until the threat
is eradicated however it turns out that
he's lying about the government
involvement and that he has actually
hired a mercenary team to kill the shark
using depth charges that team hasn't got
balls on Statham and they're dead for
sure later that night Morris and some
other officers take a boat while a
helicopter drops depth charges to kill
mag their attempt initially seems to be
successful but they mistakenly blow up a
whale instead upon having a closer look
Morris realizes their error and promptly
orders the team to retreat but
unfortunately during their escape Morris
is knocked off the boat out and becomes
the Megalodon's next victim later on the
crew learns of Morris's deceit and
decides to take matters into their own
hands determined to eliminate the
Megalodon themselves in the next scene
the crew finds out that the Megalodon is
heading towards a densely populated
Sonia beach in China in order to
safeguard the people the crew devises a
plan they decide to lure the shark away
from the beach using whale noise
recordings and then attack it with
Torpedoes from their mini subs however
before they can execute their plan Meg
attacks a Chinese wedding party on a
boat and seemingly eats the bride's dog
Meg is reinforcing a bad stereotype
before terrorizing the locals at the
beach it also devours several beachgoers
sending everyone into a state of panic a
short while later the Mana one crew uses
a whale call and diverts the shark's
attention towards them Jonas and suyin
take their positions in the mini sub to
confront mag as the giant shark shows up
Jonas firstly attracts it towards him
and leads it towards Su Yin who then
hits it with a tour torpedo
unfortunately it does no harm to the
shark
says the shark in the midst of this
chaos a group of news helicopters try to
film the event but stupidly end up
crashing into each other and the
wreckage crashes onto the crew's boat
prompting everyone to jump into the
water this forces suyan to break off the
fight and prioritize the rescue of her
crew members meanwhile Jonas alone with
his damaged torpedo engages in a head-on
confrontation with the Megalodon he
courageously fights and even manages to
inflict a significant wound on its
underbelly despite this Meg retaliates
and begins to eat up Jonas's mini sub
with no options left our hero decides to
abandon his mini sub so he grabs a knife
and a spear and swims out to face the
shark directly give me a Best Shot mine
says Jonas he stabs the spear into Meg's
eye causing the creature to bleed
heavily this attracts a swarm of regular
sharks and they Devour the weakened
Megalodon alive just when it appears as
if the danger is over a whale suddenly
arrives at the scene seemingly to prey
on Jonas but suyian intervenes in the
nick of time and rescues him with the
threat now eliminated Jonas and suyen
reunite with the rest of the Mana one
crew on a passing wedding boat in the
aftermath Jonas considers taking a
vacation with suyan indicating their
romantic interest in each other the
movie ends with the crew celebrating
their Victory as the oceans are now safe
until the second movie coming soon to
theaters near you
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for